he's like he's like the most perfect
human being we think you're perfect for
dove Thomas you lift her up where she
belongs and you love her no matter what
you guys are going strong and we
couldn't imagine a better man for dove
than you we're both professionals we
both love each other and trust each
other so much is right while she may
have been through a lot your girlfriend
never keeps her head down for too long
she's truly an inspiration and we're
happy that she's with someone who knows
her worth she's most compassionate and
most patient and most like genuine
loving person I've ever met on the
surface stuff Cameron leach the most
glamorous life but dig a little deeper
and you'll see that dove is just like
the rest of us she's had to overcome a
lot throughout the years but it's only
made her stronger keep watching to find
out how dove overcame her struggles
while remaining in the spotlight dark
childhood at first glance stuff might
seem like the girl who has it all but
she's been through her fair share of
sorrows mal and I have both been through
a lot in our lives that have made a very
layered human today when Cameron was
just 15 years old she suffered one of
the greatest losses of her life her
father Phillip Alan hawse Sherman had
taken his own life after being closeted
for years finding out the truth about
her father helped Stubb get some closure
but the hard times were just beginning
bullying you would think that someone
like dove would have an easy time making
friends but before she became a famous
Disney Channel star dub was bullied by
her classmates during an interview with
Jess jarred jr. dove explains that she
was quite an oddball when she was a kid
she used to go to school dressed up in
different costumes and was sort of a
loner
the girls at her school used to trip her
in the hallways call her names and one
time they even locked her in a janitor's
closet being rejected by her classmates
led to dub developing some serious
mental health issues however it also
gave her the drive to become the star
she is today eat your hearts out bullies
mental health struggles when it comes to
mental health issues dove isn't someone
who bottles everything up I'm very
intense I'm very complex and very
emotional she uses her voice to connect
with her fans and reassures them that
they aren't alone dove has opened up
about her struggles with mental health
via Twitter she's talked about the
negative affect social media can
have on young minds and how important it
is to stop yourself from redeeming
comments but sometimes that's easier
said than done dealing with anxiety dove
has battled and defeated depression in
the past but every now and then she
still deals with anxiety I was like
panicking myself into a black pit she
commented on how her anxiety is up and
down and how it comes and goes
but instead of letting her anxiety rule
her life dothis found ways to cope with
it she's learned to become more
disciplined in her thoughts which she
considers to be a blessing in disguise
according to dove powering through her
anxiety is the best thing she can do
because she knows that it's going to
pass sooner or later overcoming her
eating disorder it's no secret that dove
is a beautiful woman with a models
figure but even someone who looks
downright perfect can struggle with her
self-image in silence dove opened up
about her battle with anorexia and used
her struggle to connect with her fans
she explains that recovery is messy and
that those struggling should forgive
themselves for slipping up and letting
go of any shame dev wants her fans to
know that just because someone's social
media gives the illusion of a
picture-perfect life doesn't mean that
they don't have struggles of their own
letting go of a bad relationship before
dove met and fell in love with her
descendants to co-star Thomas Doherty it
means my best friends like he's my
favorite person in the world she was
engaged to Ryan McCartin on the surface
they were the perfect couple
but it didn't take long for the truth to
seep out the couple called off their
engagement after three years of dating
and Doug revealed that she left Ryan
because he treated her terribly and it
was affecting her mental health leaving
someone she loved wasn't easy but
letting go of what was keeping her down
helped her accept the love she deserved
christina grimmie when it comes to doves
inner circles she's all about quality
over quantity
unfortunately for dove her dear friend
christina grimmie life was taken by a
crazed fan back in 2016
losing christina was a major shock
pushing dove to once again realize just
how precious life truly is but nothing
could have prepared her for the loss she
would suffer after wrapping up
descendants 3 in 2019 Cameron Boyce the
amazingly talented and equally kind
Cameron Boyce unexpect
we passed away in July of 2019 a blow
that dove could never have foreseen the
pain she felt was enough to send her
spiraling down a dark path but being the
strong natured person that she is
dove chose to honor cameron by
remembering all the good times they
shared once again losing someone so
young and talented reminded of about the
importance of following your dreams you
know it really reminds you how important
everybody is how important your one life
is and leaving behind a beautiful legacy
just like Cameron Boyce had done a day
in the life of dove dove is a triple
threat who has always expressed her love
for music
she's been promising her fans new music
for the past six years and she has
finally delivered two amazing songs
blood shot and waste I'm so shocked by
how much autonomy I've been given by my
incredible label despite all of the
struggles Doug has faced in her short 23
years of life she has blossomed into a
strong and miraculous woman who leads
with love what is your favorite thing
about dove Cameron sound off in the
comments subscribe to the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time thanks
for watching
[Music]